ancient mesopotamia the land between the
two rivers is often called the first
civilization in history attributed with
the invention of rioting as well as some
of the earliest cities and empires to
ever exist this culture played a major
role in the ancient world and also came
to have a huge influence on later
developments in history the ancient
mesopotamians also had a very rich and
developed religious tradition one whose
gods and architecture is very famous to
the historically interested but which is
often also sensationalized and
misrepresented it is a rich world that
is definitely worth exploring and that's
exactly what we're going to do in this
episode based on archaeology and
scholarship what can we know about
religion in ancient mesopotamia a
religious tradition that was not only
significant in its own time and place
but which also came to play a major role
in some of the key features of the
abrahamic religions
[Laughter]
[Applause]
whether or not it's true that
mesopotamia was the first civilization
in history it's clear that it stretches
very far back in history which makes it
very significant not to mention the fact
that this civilization lasted for
basically three millennia and that's
something we need to have in mind from
the beginning we are dealing with a
quote-unquote culture or religion that
lasted for a very long time and which
like all religions and cultures changed
and evolved over time especially when
we're talking about thousands of years
so while many of the features of a
mesopotamian religion may carry across
for much of that period we should always
remember that many other features would
change and vary not only across time but
also at any given point in time
different people understood and
practiced the religion in different ways
so what we'll try to do here is give a
broad overview of some of the most
general characteristics of this
tradition with some more particular
examples when we talk about mesopotamia
we are talking about the region which is
today essentially equivalent to modern
iraq the greek name for this region
mesopotamia means literally the land
between the two rivers referring to the
tigris and euphrates rivers the
mesopotamian civilization even though it
organized itself in various different
empires and political structures was
essentially always based here the
earliest known periods of a mesopotamian
civilization was referred to as the land
of sumer and akkad which represents two
general people groups that occupy the
region
by acadian or the people of akkad we
mean a semitic people who mostly
inhabited the northern parts of
mesopotamia possibly its original
population relatively speaking and which
spoke the acadian language the earliest
known semitic language the sumerians
however which in this period occupy the
southern parts of mesopotamia are even
more mysterious many believe including
mythical stories from that time that
they arrived in the region from some
other unknown location perhaps sometime
in the 4th millennium bc
they spoke a non-semitic language and
seems to have brought with them a
complex culture including religious
beliefs and practices it is this meeting
of the sumerian and acadian cultures
their influence on each other and
co-mingling that resulted in the
mesopotamian civilization
riding was invented in this context and
sumerian the language was basically the
only language that was written being the
kind of official language in this
earliest period but as time went by the
acadian semitic population would vastly
outnumber the sumerians who basically
fizzled out resulting in that from some
time in the third millennium bc acadian
became the officially spoken language
but even though these sumerians didn't
remain as such and their language wasn't
spoken it survived as a common written
language in sacred writings or by the
educated kind of similar to how latin
functioned in europe for much of history
this becomes important for our sources
on the religion and culture of this
civilization because a lot of the
documents relating to these topics were
written in sumeria and even if that
language for most of that history wasn't
a spoken language we can also see traces
of this in the names of the many gods of
the mesopotamian pantheon who often
carry both sumerian and akkadian name so
for example the sumerian inanna was also
called ishtar in acadian and this can
become a little confusing to people when
these names are sort of used
interchangeably without any further
explanation
throughout the 3rd to 1st century's bc
mesopotamia saw the rise and fall of
several political entities sargon of
akkad at the very end of the 3rd century
founded the acadian empire perhaps the
earliest in history later hamurabi
established the great babylonian empire
making the city of babylon a major
cultural center a position that it would
hold for the rest of mesopotamia's
history the babylonians were later also
challenged by the mighty assyrians in
the north and even though dynasties rose
and fell the empire is never remaining
stable this is perhaps the most famous
image of ancient mesopotamia babylonia
in the south and assyria and the north
both of which would have great empires
consume each other and generally have a
very uneven relationship but they are
still considered to have been part of a
unified quote-unquote mesopotamian
civilization for most of history acadian
was the official language in the whole
region and most importantly for this
episode they shared essentially the same
religious tradition so in all this what
was the religion of the ancient
mesopotamians well at its core it was a
polytheistic religion which means that
it involved many different deities
myths about those deities and rituals
aimed at keeping the relationship
between humans and those deities on good
terms it is therefore a religious
tradition that is very familiar and
similar to other polytheistic religions
in antiquity so if you know
a thing or two about ancient egyptian
religion or ancient greek religion and
ancient arabian religion perhaps
you will recognize a lot of things here
too and just as in all those societies
religion and the religious cult was an
essential part of life and society to
the ancient mesopotamians it was
essential for the very maintenance of
the world and its order for the health
of the individual and a society and as
is usually the case it was essential for
the state and for the king or emperor
whose authority and legitimacy often
rested on his connection to the gods or
his role as supervisor of the cult
religion in other words was an integral
part of every aspect of life running
through the very veins of mesopotamian
society because we can't talk to the
people who lived this tradition or
directly be in that context we can never
grasp the full extent of what this
religion was
since it is in essence an extinct
tradition we have to rely on historical
sources from that period sources thus
from millennia ago this means
archaeological finds like temples and
buildings or other objects but above all
it means writings and documents that
refer to religious practice or sentiment
in some way we have hymns and prayers to
the gods which give us some idea of how
these things functioned but this also
means that we are limited to the
perspectives of only one
section of the population the elites
mostly because they were the ones that
had the ability to read and write these
things down not only that but we're also
limited to the particular things that
they thought were important to write
down and document which in many cases
might have been the least
important things when it comes to their
religious tradition
in short we are limited when it comes to
our understanding of the mesopotamian
religion because of the
limits of our sources but we still have
enough to be able to reconstruct
somewhat of a
picture of what this religious tradition
looked like we're going to begin by
looking at its mythological aspects
namely the gods divine beings and the
stories told about them and the world
even though my opinion is that the core
of religions are in their practical
aspect i think it could be beneficial to
start here and then move our way down to
the praxis the mesopotamian pantheon
consisted of an innumerable amount of
deities each one more fascinating than
the next
some of them were possibly of sumerian
origin others from the semitic culture
who were often also blended and
syncretized with each other the words
used for their equivalent of our god or
deity were dingier in sumerian and illu
in acadian which shows you the
similarity of acadian to other semitic
languages like aramaic hebrew or arabic
the gods were the creators of the
universe and also ruled over it and
everyone in it they inspired great
reverence from the peoples in the region
being seen and depicted essentially
through metaphors of kingship and rule
just like the kings and emperors ruled
over the people in his kingdom the gods
were kings of all of the universe and
all of mankind it was the duty of the
human being to obey the will of the
divine sovereigns and to worship them
this was a religion where the gods were
transcendent standing above everything
in the so-called on high or heaven and
humans were their servants the gods were
heavenly rulers of the world not
divinities that inhabited it at least
not in the later developed periods there
is no concept of gods residing in the
hearts or souls of human beings in that
way or in objects of the world
necessarily although the gods were
considered to be able to reside in a
statue or image as we will see later the
gods were depicted and described in
anthropomorphic ways just like in greek
religion for example the stories about
the gods depict them as rather
human-like having emotions getting angry
sometimes being petty or acting in
questionable ways also similar to kings
the gods belong to a kind of divine
dynasty all being related and part of
the same family essentially to name or
go through all of the gods here would be
impossible because there are hundreds if
not thousands of them but again similar
to other polytheistic religions the
different gods were often associated
with things like natural phenomena or
other human concepts for example shamash
in acadian or utu in sumerian was the
god of the son
nana
sin was the god of the moon enki
was the god of wisdom and so on
it does not appear that there was a
direct correspondence here though like
an egyptian religion where the gods were
often literally identified as these
natural phenomena instead the
mesopotamian gods were divine beings in
control of these aspects of the world
although there are probably exceptions
to this too as always the gods were also
usually associated with a particular
locale or city and seen as the patron
deity of that city so the god an or anu
and inanna ishtar were the patron
deities of the city uruk which is often
considered the first true city in
history enki was the patron deity of the
city eridu sin was the god of ur ashore
was the god of the city
ashur you get the idea these cities
would be the main center of worship for
these gods and here is a clear example
of how the religion could vary you would
encounter a different kind of cult or
religious focus depending on which city
you were in even though they all belong
to the same general system now even
though we can't do a rundown of all the
gods it is true that the pantheon had a
kind of built-in hierarchy and some gods
were more important and prominent than
others in particular there were a few
gods that were the most common and
powerful throughout mesopotamian history
there was anu the father and founder of
the divine dynasty he is the source
literally the ancestor of all the other
gods and thus in some ways he is the
highest god of them all also associated
with the sky in heaven
enlil was for much of history the most
powerful godo he was the son of anu and
at some point appears to have inherited
or taken over the role as the ruler of
all the gods and the universe thus
making him the center of worship and the
chief god for much of the religious cult
enlil was also the god associated with
heir and with the city of nipur
enki or ia another son of anu was the
wisest and most active of the gods he
would become very important for various
creation myths and played a particularly
central role in the creation and
fashioning of the human being inanna or
ishtar was the most powerful and
prominent female goddess often
representing the female divine as lady
or mother of the gods in general but
also more specifically as a particular
goddess associated with things like love
sex and war and around which there are
fascinating mythological stories there
is also the aforementioned shamash or
otto the god of the sun and sin nana the
god of the moon but as i've said things
also change and evolve for example in
the second millennium with the
establishment of the babylonian empire
another new god was exalted to the point
of even eventually replacing en little
as the chief god this god was marduk
marduk was the son of enki and would
take on many of the roles that other
gods had had previously he became
associated with creation and concepts
like justice and agriculture he would
remain the patron deity of the city of
babylon and is called at its center in
this most significant of mesopotamian
cities in the classical era similarly in
the assyrian empire the god ashur took
on a similar role as the most important
god which had its center of worship in
the assyrian capital named after him so
as you can tell there's a lot of variety
and diversity here but these are some of
the most central and recurring gods and
deities in this religious tradition and
we will get to know them as well as
other gods a bit more deeply as the
discussion goes on not only is there a
general hierarchy among the gods in this
way but they are also sometimes divided
into groups
there is often talk about two general
groups of gods the anunnaki and the igi
this topic and the difference between
these categories is a very difficult one
scholars disagree on the relationship
between them and what they signify the
anunnaki as the name suggests are gods
who are descendants of the older
dimension anu and ki the goddess of
earth
in some of the earliest sources these
appear to be the highest gods ruling
over that other group of deities the igi
who are kind of like their servants
but later in history these names seem to
have been reversed for some reason the
iggy serving as the high gods and vice
versa
at other times they seem to be used
synonymously i'm not going to pretend
like i have the answer to this question
it is one that confuses scholars and
historians who are actual experts on
this topic and so i am in no position to
speak on it in that way just know that
these categories exist and that the
relationship between them is very
uncertain but regardless all these gods
are part of a rich and vast mythological
tradition which spans across the
millennia of mesopotamian civilization
myths about the origins of the gods and
subsequently of the whole universe are
just as fascinating as usual and deserve
to be explored here the gods created the
world as we know it that is indisputable
to the mesopotamians but who created the
gods or more accurately where did the
gods come from now when it comes to
mythology things are very complicated
one thing that many people often get
wrong is the very nature of mythological
stories in our religious culture in the
west which is so hugely influenced by
the abrahamic religions in particular we
are used to the idea that there is a
definite version of events when it comes
to creation or religious history that
there is a story that each religion sort
of adheres to and this is simply not
true
myths by their nature are fluid they are
always changing and adapting being
retold by people who may perhaps
reformulate certain aspects to fit
certain contexts myths are in motion
there is never just one version of a
particular story or myth and there
wasn't supposed to be really the fact
that things could be conceived in
different ways was not seen as
detrimental to the truths of these
stories this is true of the greek myths
it's true of egyptian mythology and it
is true in mesopotamia as well so as we
go on to explore various myths and
stories about the creation of the world
or the gods we don't have just one
account we have many different accounts
that can sometimes
drastically differ sometimes
fundamentally different from each other
for example probably the most famous and
complete account of creation and
theogony in this culture comes from the
enuma elish meaning literally when on
high but often going under the title the
epic of creation which was discovered in
1849 and probably dates to sometime in
the 7th century bc in babylonia this is
just a rather late source but it tells a
relatively complete account one which
has become standard in retelling some of
the central myths and which i'll be
relying on to a major degree here too
but it should always be kept in mind
that this is only one version of events
and i will also be giving some contrary
examples from other mythological stories
the gods existed long before the
universe did while the great anu is the
father of the current divine dynasty he
himself had many ancestors gods who
stretched back since long before any
universe
at this point there existed only the
gods
as far back as the mesopotamians could
conceive even before the lion of the
divine couples they thought there
existed a divine principle called namu
the lady of the gods the mother who gave
birth to the universe
this principle was conceived of as a
kind of sea or watery substance in the
words of the scholar jean potero quotes
simultaneously a supernatural figure
place and matter it was believed to be
of a watery nature marine
is placed beyond the ancestors of anu as
if it was a matter of an individual
theogony even earlier than the oldest
divinities
other later accounts which don't
necessarily have to contradict the first
instead tell of two massive waters sea
or salty water called tiamat and fresh
water called apsu
these two divine forces coupled so to
say and gave birth to the first gods we
then often see a very long line of gods
a dynasty stretching for various lengths
but always being really really long
until we reach anu there seems to have
been the idea that the gods kind of
developed over time in a teleological
sense that the earliest gods were kind
of incomplete or imperfect getting
better over time until we finally reach
anu who is the perfected form of
divinity and who subsequently founded
the current dynasty of gods that then
fashioned the universe as we then get to
the actual creation of the world as we
know it only after the existence of the
god anu and his
offspring things get even more diverse
there are so many different versions of
how this happened with different gods
serving as the main figure there is no
conception of a creation x nihilo in
this religion that is a creation from
nothingness the universe is fashioned
from what is already there in some
accounts there existed an original
spheric chaotic mass
then heaven and earth were separated
from each other creating the universe
court
in those days those ancient days in
those nights those ancient nights in
those years those ancient years after on
high had been moved away from below
after below had been separated from on
high after ahn had carried off on high
after enlil had carried off below
then heaven and earth the gods anu and
ki as a married couple essentially have
sex and produce all the vegetation in
other parts of the world
another account describes the god enlil
as ejaculating into the earth to
fertilize it others give the wise god
enki or ia a central role as creator but
again the most complete and famous
account comes from the epic of creation
if you remember this story was written
in acadian and in the babylonian empire
in the 7th century bc which is when the
god marduk had become exalted as the
chief god it is as natural that in this
account marduk plays the decisive role
in the creation of the world in the epic
of creation it is told how marduk saves
the other gods from destruction when
tiamat the great primitive universal
mother wanted them annihilated marduk
then defeats tiamat and creates the
world from her remains from her body
quote he split her in two like a fish
for drying half of her he set up and
made as a cover heaven spreading the
other half of her as cover he
established the earth after he had
completed his task inside tiamat he
spread his net let all within escape he
formed the
something of heaven and netherworld
tightening their bond
regardless of the story you follow the
world was created by the gods that much
is certain and the mesopotamian picture
of the cosmos was basically one of a
sphere the upper part of which was known
as the on high as we saw on the quotes
which can roughly be called or
translated as heaven where the gods
reside and the lower part of which was
called the below where some lesser gods
reside them where all ghosts or souls
will go after death
right in the middle of the sphere
separating heaven and below are two
great seas basically at the opposite
ends of which are enormous mountains
that held up the firmament of heaven and
in the middle of this central part of
the cosmos is the earth the place where
humans reside
furthermore at the center of this earth
is mesopotamia and at least according to
the babylonians at the very center of
mesopotamia and thus of the world is the
city of babylon itself
this general cosmology helps us better
grasp some of the concepts in the
mesopotamian religion and indeed the
human being would come to play a central
role in the purpose of this creation the
stories about and surrounding the
creation of the human being are
fascinating and it is here that we find
some of those really strong similarities
with the bible so as i retell these
myths see if you can spot where those
similarities are the most famous account
of human creation comes from a beautiful
epic poem called the atrajasis named
after its titular hero
it was written in old babylonia sometime
in the 18th to 17th centuries bc that
poem tells the story like this
before human beings the anunnaki the
high gods had made the igi group of gods
their servants working and toiling for
them tending the fields on earth etc but
because the igi were gods and immortal
they basically were able to go on strike
and oppose the oppressive situation
destroying the tools used for work etc
as a solution to this situation the wise
god enki decided that they should create
a new creature a new being one that was
mortal and could take the place of the
egy as servants and so it was that the
human being was fashioned from clay as
well as the blood and flesh of some of
those other geeky gods and began to
serve their function as workers for the
gods essentially but at this time humans
could live for a very long time like for
tens and even hundreds of thousands of
years and there existed no such thing as
illnesses and these things the
reproductive possibilities were thus
almost limitless and very soon there
were a whole lot of human beings so many
in fact that the great god enlil became
annoyed with all the noise that humans
were making for this reason in his anger
he decided to have them all annihilated
thus representing the most extreme
example of a grumpy old neighbor in
history he tried various ways of killing
off the humans the most decisive and
final of these was that he sent a great
flood that would get rid of them once
and for all
but that other god the wise enki was
distraught over this he didn't want to
let the whole purpose of creating humans
go to waste which would put the gods
back in that predicament from before
so he decided to save humankind by
allowing the titular character atrahasis
to survive the flood by putting him and
his family in an unsinkable boat along
with what they needed to restore the
fauna of the world afterwards
and it is after this as a result of
endless action and annoyance that enki
came up with another solution they would
now limit the lifespan of humans so that
they wouldn't live so long and created
things like disease to combat them from
multiplying too much i don't need to
tell you this but this is obviously
identical to the story of noah and the
ark in the bible and many scholars
believe that that biblical story
originally comes from these mesopotamian
myths indeed the flood myth shows up in
various sources in mesopotamia with the
main human character having different
names but the basic narrative remaining
the same we also saw other similarities
to the abrahamic accounts like the
fashioning of the human being from clay
even in a topic like the afterlife we
can see similarities
in general the ancient mesopotamians
seem to have accepted death as an
inevitable part of life this can be
clearly seen in the epic of gilgamesh
the most famous piece of literature from
the mesopotamian civilization and often
considered the oldest work of literature
in history
in this work the hero gilgamesh goes on
a long journey to find the secrets to
immortality only in the end to spoiler
alert realize that it is basically
impossible
in the anthropology of this religion the
human being was thought to have a kind
of ghost that lived on after the death
of the physical body which would then
travel to the underworld called aralu
where you would spend all of eternity
regardless of how you lived your life
this is practically identical to the
notion of sheol as the ultimate destiny
for all souls after death in the hebrew
bible
but that is the basic story about the
creation of the world and the human
being the purpose of human life is to
serve the gods humans were created as
workers essentially to work for the gods
and make sure they were comfortable so
to say the gods are monarchs who rule
over all the world and all human beings
and who are in control of all events and
forces but exactly how were humans
supposed to serve the gods what did they
do to fulfill this purpose of their
creation
this is where we get to the practical
aspects of the religion the religious
cult of ancient mesopotamia was
primarily centered on the temple
there were temples and shrines located
all across the region dedicated to the
different gods and in which ritual
activity took place
primarily in the great cities there was
usually one major temple complex
dedicated to the patron god of that city
for example there was the e absu temple
in eredu dedicated to the god enki there
was the ikur temple in nipur dedicated
to ending and in the babylonian period
there was the massive e temenki complex
in babylon dedicated to marduk
these temples were massive complexes
that basically served at the very heart
of the city it consisted of various
different buildings with different
functions including a more sacred shrine
or holy of holies where the image of the
god or gods were contained probably the
most famous and spectacular aspect of
the temple complexes were the large
towers known as the ziggurat
these were towers with ascending
platforms connected by a stairwell with
a platform on the top
historians are a bit unsure exactly how
these towers functioned and what their
purpose was but the famous ancient greek
historian herodotus reports that there
was a shrine at the very top of the
ziggurat where rituals took place and
this seems to be corroborated by
mesopotamian accounts too in a tablet
from the seleucid period at the very end
of classical mesopotamian civilization
we find a description of the liturgy in
the temple quote at the first arrival of
night on the roof of the high chamber of
the ziggurat at the moment when the
stars of anu the greatest in heaven
appear and in urus a major of unto the
greatest in heaven hymns will be sung
end of quote the most famous igurat is
probably that in babylon dedicated to
marduk which seems to have been the
largest some estimates suggest that it
may have towered at 90 meters high or
about 300 feet which is pretty crazy to
think about some have argued there is
this ziggurat in babylon that is
referred to as the tower of babel in the
bible
the temples were thought to be the
houses of the god it was in a way like a
shelter for the god in which he or she
would be provided with all they needed
for a comfortable existence
the temple complex included many
buildings apartments and more for the
god and his consort or his family it was
almost like a city within the city with
its own dedicated personnel there were
cooks that lived in the temple whose job
it was to provide food for the gods and
there were of course a dedicated class
of priests both men and women who
performed rituals on a daily basis these
priests served the god as part of their
profession but otherwise seems to have
led regular lives getting married and
other such mundane things although there
are examples of certain groups of
priestesses or priests living more
secluded almost cloistered lives as well
again the gods were thought to reside in
these houses they were represented and
kind of embodied in the cultic statues
which stood in the most sacred rooms of
the temple
it was believed that the gods were in
some way literally present in these
divine images and the latter was thus
treated like the actual god thus the
duties of the priest and temple
personnel was to make sure that the
deity embodied in the image housed in
the shrine led a comfortable life this
included the ritual of feeding the gods
multiple times every day animals would
be sacrificed and all other kinds of
food and drink was prepared by the cook
and presented to the gods by the priests
the drinks were likely poured as
libations of the god and the food once
it had been offered to the god was
probably distributed to temple personnel
afterwards and perhaps to charity as
well they would also clothe the god in
various adorned clothing clean the gods
through bathing and in general treat
them like you would treat a king or
queen the recurring metaphor through
which the mesopotamians understood their
relationship to the gods we can see
again the very strong anthropomorphism
of the deities regardless of how the
most exalted theologies conceived of the
gods as such they were depicted
described and treated in strongly
anthropomorphic ways like human royals
that ruled over the universe they even
had social lives of a sort the statue of
god could go on trips to other cities to
visit other gods this was done through
portable houses or palanquins in which
they would be carried from one location
to another as you might have noticed
from some of the examples and courts
there is sometimes reference to god and
singular or focus on a specific god and
this is true words we often use in these
contexts like polytheism or monotheism
can often get pretty blurry and can fail
to properly present the complexity of
these religious traditions we have
already explored this topic in the
context of ancient egypt in a previous
episode and much the same can be said
here now there is no trace of anything
like a strict monotheism or even the
idea of a singular divine essence of
which the others are part as in the
egyptian tradition but in ancient
mesopotamia there is indeed often a
single god that is at the core of
worship as we saw different cities
focused on a particular deity but beside
that there was usually also a single god
that was seen as the supreme deity and
the focus of worship throughout the land
for most of history that god was enlil
but in the babylonian period it
gradually turned to marduk the patron
god of the city of babylon
furthermore most people seemed to have
had a personal god that their devotions
were dedicated to in other words we see
in ancient mesopotamia a tendency
towards what is known as hinotheism the
primary worship of a supreme god without
the exclusion of other gods from
existence this can be an important
factor to have in mind to better
understand the religious sentiments of
this culture and of many others in
antiquity in addition to these quantum
mundane aspects of temple practice such
as feeding and cleaning the priests also
performed more elaborate rituals and
liturgies again animal sacrifice seems
to have played a major role but only in
so far as it served as the meal for the
gods right as food for the gods but in
relation to this the priest would also
say prayers sing hymns praising the gods
and play music
indeed music seemed to have played a
major role in the temple liturgy with
various instruments like flutes loots
and drums being used to accompany the
hymns and rituals the hymns and prayers
of the mesopotamians were highly
reverential and praising for example a
sumerian hymn from the end of the third
millennium begins like this quote
o well-born o well-born o king whom
enlil has named o well-born o well-born
ninurta whom enlil has named i wish to
celebrate your name o my king
ninurta your man your man i wish to
celebrate your name
you make the speckled barley grow in the
fields you fill the pool with carp and
perch you make the reeds and rush grow
in the cane fields you fill the forest
with wild grazers you make the tamarisks
grow on the steps you garnish gardens
and vineyards with honey and wine and
you will grant the place a longer life
it was the responsibility of human
beings to keep the gods happy as we saw
this was in fact the very purpose behind
their creation and this wasn't limited
only to the temple cults and the priests
regular people also practice devotion in
various ways it seems even though we
know much less about this because they
were rarely in a position to write
things down so we don't hear much from
these people but in one account a father
is giving advice to his son on how to
live a properly pious life and thus reap
the rewards and it sounds like this
quote
every day worship your god sacrifice and
benediction are the proper accompaniment
of incense present your free will
offering to your god for this is proper
toward the gods
prayer supplication and prostration
offer him daily and you will get your
award
then you will have full communion with
your god
reverence begets favor sacrifice
prolongs life and prayer atones for
guilt
we can see that a regular day for a well
at least a pious everyday person would
include giving offerings to the god as
well as prayers prostrations and
possibly other modes of worship because
even though the religious cult was
primarily centered in the temple it was
also something that all of society took
part in
there would be recurring festivals on
set points during the year which would
involve more elaborate rituals involving
the gods mythical stories about the gods
could be sort of recreated in an almost
theatrical way using the images and
statues of the deities for example
there's one festival about the
the marriage between two gods and in
this
festival the two images of those gods
would be brought together they would
have the marriage ceremony and then they
would both be placed in the sort of bed
chamber overnight so that they could uh
consummate their marriage so to say so
these kinds of festivals took place and
this involved the city and would most
likely have involved a very festive
atmosphere not just in the temple but in
the whole city and perhaps in the whole
country the maintenance and worship of
the gods were not only thought to keep
order in the universe but also to
society and the kingdom itself just like
in other ancient cultures like in
ancient egypt where the pharaoh's
connection to the gods were essential
for his legitimacy and role as pharaoh
the mesopotamian royals also legitimized
their rule based on their connection to
the cult in fact the king was seen as
the general supervisor of the whole cult
he was responsible for the cults and
that the gods were provided with all
that they needed which obviously gives
him legitimacy as leader
the kings always made sure to emphasize
that they were servants of the gods and
dedicated to serving them and thus
upholding order in the world and society
going back to our friend john botero
quotes the kings willingly glorify
themselves notably in their dedicatory
and commemorative inscriptions for their
zeal in religious behavior frequently
taking the titles of curators and
servants of the sanctuaries end of quote
indeed the annual new year celebration
in babylon would culminate in a scene
where the king was literally dragged by
his ear by one of the priests into the
sanctuary of marduk and then made to
kneel and say prayers
of praise sort of emphasizing his role
as servant that he was serving the god
it was obviously a very direct way of
connecting political rule with the
religious cult in order to legitimize
the king through ritualizing the
historian piotr michalovsky writes
quotes mesopotamian kings similar to
monarchs and many other times and
cultures were first and foremost
mediators between the mundane and
transcendent orders brute force aside
all other royal attributes derived from
this function end quote the patronage of
a god was a significant factor in the
empire or kingdom it seems that the
earliest cities in mesopotamia
essentially grew from places of worship
of particular gods which expanded and
became more powerful and these locales
and cults eventually were systematized
into a single system we can also see
this kind of phenomenon very clearly in
the exalting of marduk to chief god in
association with the rise of babylonia
marduk had been the local patron god of
the city of babylon previously but was a
relatively insignificant god ending was
always the supreme god at this time but
as babylon grew into an empire under
people like hamurabi suddenly marduk
became increasingly exalted as the
supreme god in various texts and myths
from this time it makes complete sense
when you think about it by making the
god associated with your capital city
the most powerful god this legitimized
your rule and empire it gave the
babylonians the authority to rule since
they in a way represented the most
powerful of the gods and we also see a
similar situation in assyria with the
god ashur it was after all the gods that
were in control of everything including
who was and wasn't king and because the
gods were in control of everything they
also knew the future the parts of their
plan that hadn't happened yet
and aside from the fact that the
religious practices already mentioned
were meant to maintain and keep the gods
happy there were also other religious
practices that were aimed more at the
benefits of humans themselves what john
botero refers to as the sacramental cult
this included various things that would
fall under our category of occult
sciences such as various forms of magic
and primarily divination the gods could
communicate messages about future events
directly to human intermediaries the
latter thus being equivalent to the
prophets of the israelite religion
through these prophets who were probably
just random regular people the gods
would communicate certain things to the
king or to society
but it was also believed that the
writings or intentions of the gods could
be read in creation itself
it is for this reason that divination
became a very prominent practice in
mesopotamia with various techniques
professional diviners could find out
things about the future a future that in
this culture wasn't set in stone but
could be changed by turning to the gods
but the kind of divination that was most
famous and strongly associated with the
ancient babylonians in particular was
what we would call astrology
the stars and heavenly bodies were
considered to contain signs that could
be interpreted to learn the future and
the workings of the gods indeed while it
doesn't seem like the mesopotamians saw
the stars as literal gods as would
become common later in antiquity the
stars were given important roles as kind
of symbols for the gods a certain star
or constellation could be associated
with a particular deity for all of these
reasons above astrology and the
interpretations of the heavenly vaults
became very important to the
mesopotamians they developed a very
sophisticated tradition of astronomy and
astrology which would greatly influence
later movements in later antiquity even
as the mesopotamian civilization proper
had disappeared we see people who engage
in astrology essentially tracing that
whole practice back to the babylonians
to the mesopotamians this practice was
intimately connected to religion and
with the gods there is an absolutely
beautiful prayer which encapsulates the
religious nature and importance of
astrological divination which goes like
this quote
the nobles are in deep sleep
the bars of the doors are lowered the
bolts are in place
also the ordinary people do not utter a
sound
their always open doors are locked
the gods and goddesses of the country
shamash sin adad and ishtad have gone
home to heaven to sleep they will not
give decisions or verdicts tonight
knight has put on her veil the palace is
quiet the countryside does not utter a
sound
only the lonely traveler calls to the
god for protection and even the one for
whom the divine decision is sought
remains asleep shamash the just judge
the father of the underprivileged has
likewise gone to his bedchamber
may the great gods of the night shining
firestar heroic ira bowstar yolk star
wagon goat star goat fish star serpent
star stand by and put a propitious sign
on the extra of the lamb i am blessing
now for the extispacy i'll perform
tomorrow a very poetic prayer that
paints just an amazing picture we can
probably explore these more occult
aspects of mesopotamian culture and
religion more deeply in future episodes
this was a culture that was inhabited by
various
supernatural beings that could
hurt human beings or
make
was the source of evil essentially what
we would refer to as demons today these
demons would be the cause of much evil
and bad behavior in the world and there
were exorcistic rituals and practices
that developed in order to make these
demons go away with the help of the gods
and it is also likely that the
prominence of these kinds of creatures
in this culture also influenced the
prominence of similar creatures in later
religious traditions and cultures as
well there are even things like
witchcraft and other fascinating stuff
that we haven't had a time to cover
today needless to say the religion of
ancient mesopotamia had long lasting
effects the great civilization as we
know it essentially died out around the
turn of the common era after being
conquered and ruled by alexander the
great and the seleucids as well as the
achaemenid persians but it's also
precisely in this meeting with the wider
world that this culture came to have
such a major impact on other religions
in the middle east and the mediterranean
region it was a tradition that stretched
back for thousands of years to the very
beginnings of human civilization and was
of course respected for that very reason
traces of their beliefs and practices
can be seen in later cultures and
religions of the region from greek
philosophy to the astral religions that
would appear here and as we have seen
probably even into some of the core
features and stories from the bible and
the abrahamic religions to understand
the history of religion and human
thought in general one cannot leave out
the mesopotamians and i hope i have now
given you enough reason to understand
why
i hope this episode has been informative
and interesting i would like to give a
special shout out and thanks to all of
my patrons who keep this channel going i
would not be able to do any of this
without you guys and i am deeply
indebted and and so thankful for all of
your support if anyone else out there
wants to become a patron it really is
the best way to support this channel and
what we do here um
if you want to become a patron you want
to support this channel then i will
leave links to that stuff in the
description and probably also in a
pinned comment so you can check it out
there for now that's all we're going to
talk about today about mesopotamian
religion but it's surely a topic that we
will return to at some point to dive
deeper into some of its particularities
and all those juicy
details and tradition it really is such
a fascinating topic but until then
i will see you next time
[Music]
you